le point de départ de cette enquête une
lettre adressée en juillet 2014 par le
groupe d'opposition alors présidée par
jean claude robert
une lettre signée par l'ensemble des
membres du groupe et adressée au
procureur de dijon
les opposants de gauche s'inquiète de
possibles détournements de fonds ou de
délit de favoritisme
une information que nous a confirmé
aujourd'hui colette popard actuelle
présidente du groupe d'opposition est
signataire du courrier
l'article de mediapart fait mention de
trois pistes sur lesquelles se seraient
penchés les gendarmes de la section de
recherches de besançon
tout d'abord la situation personnelle de
pascal grappin
cet ancien conseiller du président
sauvadet occupe depuis 2009 un poste de
chargé de mission sur la politique
d'insertion et de solidarité
un poste dont la réalité serait mise en
doute selon le site internet
d'information les enquêteurs se seraient
également intéressés à l'utilisation du
budget de formation des élus mais aussi
aux marchés obtenus par la société
bygmalion pour la fabrication du journal
départemental côte d'or magazine
de son côté le cabinet de françois
sauvadet a refusé notre demande
d'interview et nous a renvoyés vers la
déclaration faite au journal le bien
public
dans celui ci le président du
département se dit calme et serein et
ajoute j'ai été très surpris de
l'article de mediapart
l'article relate des allégations de
l'opposition départementale en 2014
au sujet de dossiers qui ont fait en
leur temps l'objet de délibérations de
l'assemblée en toute transparence
l' enquête du parquet national
financiers sa tâche sera certainement à
relire ses délibérations